[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de salud de
nuestro espacio france24 llamado directo
américa para ello como siempre todas las
mañanas me acompaña en el estudio más
romeros a la mar bienvenida a hoy martes
felices mañana vamos a hablar del día de
la visibilidad lésbica por supuesto de
las discriminaciones que pueden sufrir
lamentablemente las mujeres lesbianas en
atención médica impensable
así es raúl las discriminaciones son
muchas y nos vamos a centrar en una
concretamente que es todo lo que tiene
que ver con la salud sexual y las
consultas ginecológicas pero antes de
empezar unas breves pinceladas de que
las mujeres lesbianas igual que la
población es el lg en general tiene más
riesgo de sufrir discriminación social
económica eso lleva a desigualdades
sociales que también conllevan problemas
de salud y que en general hay una
reticencia generalizada en toda esta
población lgp incluida las mujeres las
mujeres lesbianas personas trans mujeres
también bisexuales a acudir a consultas
médicas pues por el miedo al rechazo que
puedan sufrir ahí que ocurre entonces
marc alrededor de la salud sexual de las
mujeres limpiara en en este caso
particular de un pues la verdad es que
en general pocos datos cosas que ya nos
habla pues de una cierta lógica de
invisibilización de las prácticas
sexuales que pueden tener las mujeres
lesbianas y de los riesgos de salud que
conllevan pero bueno a falta de datos lo
que hicimos fue recoger algunos
testimonios para entender pues cómo
operan estas lógicas de la
invisibilización y de la discriminación
en estos casos
la primera cosa que sucedió cuando fui
al médico por cuestiones
ginecológicas fue que me pregunto me
hice las preguntas de licor como tienes
vida sexual activa si usas métodos
anticonceptivos no estás planeando
quedar embarazada no entonces porque no
están sometidos a métodos
anticonceptivos soy lesbiana y que él me
respondía como ah pero ustedes no tienen
sexo
nunca he tenido información sobre
prevención en prácticas de riesgo u
otras prácticas de cuidado creo que lo
único que plantean es plazo planificar e
incluso cuando explícitamente he dicho
que no lo necesito que no tengo
posibilidades de quedar en embarazo
entonces
bueno siento el espacio ginecológico
para mí es estresante e impersonal y
absolutamente vulnerador de muchos
planos de la salud
y pues también un testimonio que no
pudimos transmitir por problemas
técnicos nos hablaba de que le negara
una citología que es un examen
importante para descubrir el virus del
papiloma humano y para comprobar en
general el estado de salud de una
persona también porque consideró que no
había prácticas de riesgo pero imágenes
de usted mar si esto pasa en el espacio
médico y sobre todo en una cita de
ginecología tan importante como ósea y
espacios que son especialmente
vulnerables por supuesto porque estás
como pues completamente pues desnuda
prácticamente aún con un especialista de
salud necesita seguridad necesitas
sentirte respaldada y mira lo que pasa
cuáles son las principales errores en
estas consultas ya vemos que no son
pocos no son pocos no el principal por
ejemplo es este asumir que no hay
prácticas de riesgo en el sexo entre dos
mujeres cuando las prácticas sexuales no
dependen de la orientación sexual sino
también dependen pues bueno de lo que
quieran hacer las dos personas que estén
implicadas básicamente no precisamente
sobre esto sobre la posibilidad de
transmisión de enfermedades sexuales le
preguntamos a la ginecóloga maría
alejandra cifuentes y estacional que nos
contó
el mayor mito que debemos retirar sobre
todo de las relaciones lésbicas es que
este tipo de relaciones no pueden tener
ningún tipo de enfermedad de transmisión
sexual eso es un error
cualquier relación sexual sea la pareja
que sea que tenga contacto de fluído con
fluido ya tenemos un riesgo de
enfermedad de transmisión sexual
como decíamos complementando la
información cualquier intercambio de
fluidos pueden entrañar un riesgo de
transmisión sexual y hay mucosas en la
vagina en el ano también en la boca eso
pues hay muchas posibilidades que
debemos tener en cuenta entonces en el
sexo entre mujeres existen posibilidades
de barreras existen preservativos
femeninos existen barreras de látex tipo
guantes existen unos cuadrantes que
pueden servir para varias prácticas
sexuales entre ellas el sexo oral
también existen pues la posada de usar
condones para juguetes sexuales si es
que se usan pero el problema es que
todas estas posibilidades no se
consiguen con facilidad hay una de
algunas de las chicas que entrevistamos
nos comentaban que esperan que otras
personas vengan de otros países para
pedirles que les compren para atraerlas
entonces pues todo esto también forma
parte de esa civilización que hoy se
intenta romper y por eso aquí en directo
américa de france 24 tanto en salud como
nuestro posterior invitada del día
nuestras invitadas del día estamos
dándole visibilidad a las mujeres
lesbianas o como se lo merecen o qué
consecuencias tiene para la salud de las
mujeres sufrí de esta discriminación
marc en los espacios médicos claro vamos
a lo peor no esas consecuencias son
amplias también se lo preguntamos a la
ginecóloga a maría alejandra cifuentes
veamos lo que nos dijo
la discriminación y la falta de
información de algunos profesionales de
la salud ginecólogos sobre las
relaciones lésbicas puede hacer que este
tipo de pacientes se sientan
discriminadas inconformes mal informadas
y sobre todo mal entendidas y esto hace
que haya mucha deserción sobre este tipo
de consultas haciendo que estas mujeres
se pierdan por muchos años de ir a una
consulta médica por miedo a ser
discriminadas y ser juzgadas ese miedo a
ser discriminada de ese miedo a ser
juzgadas también nos lo comentaban en
esos testimonios que recogimos
esto ha generado en mi miedo y pereza
sobre todo de intentar hacerme entender
una interlocución que se sabe que muchas
veces no va a salir bien cuando pide una
cita ginecológica pienso en seguir o no
siempre termino yendo pero me da pereza
me da pereza tener que aumentar mi
juicios de valor o tener que defender
quién soy entonces que deberían esperar
las mujeres lesbianas en una consulta
ginecológica y alrededor de su salud
sexual primero pues que no se asuma nada
alrededor de sus prácticas sexuales que
se las escuche dos encontrar
verdaderamente información información
profesional alrededor de riesgos y de
cómo cuidarse y por último como bien
decíamos espacios seguros en un lugar
donde estamos especialmente vulnerables
así es mar muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información de salud
en este día y pasamos precisamente a
seguir hablando sobre este día de
visibilidad lésbica con nuestras dos
invitadas del día de hoy marc gracias